so last week I give a challenge to you
about you doing a specific amount of
activity in a week whether it's 200
calls 20 appointments certain lot of
numbers you send out and you actually
coming through and one my question is
for you if you actually came through on
your commitments last week and whether
you did or not that leads me into my
points today and here's what it is
see when I first got started to business
I was all into listening to all these
motivational tapes listen I got a hold
of every single one of them and I
listened to him over and over and over
and over and I was just so motive and I
wanted to motivate everybody motive a
motive oh I'm like you know it was all I
want to motivate every single person I
come across and then finally got to a
point where I said pad one if all you do
is motivate somebody they walk away
excited and they don't do anything about
it what are you really motivating people
for for your own self satisfaction so
people say oh my gosh what a great -
message you just gave you such an
amazing motivational speaker I cannot
believe you speak that way then it came
to a point where I'm matured as a person
that I no longer needed the attention
for people to say Pat you're amazing
don't get me wrong I love getting
recognition for my kids I love getting
recognition for my wife for my family
for my blood
and from the people I work with on a
daily basis I love that but to get it
for validation eventually got to a point
where I said I gotta figure out a way to
learn the fundamentals of business and
you know what happened I was
disappointed let me tell you why I was
disappointed when I seek to find out
what are the fundamentals of what these
massively successful people that was 20
to 23 years old you know what it was
they master all the boring stuff that
none of these motivational speakers
talked about on these videos they don't
you know why because who the hell wants
to know about boring stuff what what
video that talks about boring stuff is
really gonna go viral it's not gonna go
far watch this video today look how many
views it gets let's look at the
commentary of this video this is not
gonna be great video that's gonna go
viral you know why because it's boring
you're waiting for a secret you're
waiting for me to give you some massive
special significant thing that I'm going
to tell you
it's gonna change your life this week no
no it's what I what what I challenge you
to do last week would just write out
your commitments and follow through with
it can you do that for 60 months can you
do that for 60 months you can you do it
for 60 months because I like guarantees
in life and you know what I know about
guarantees if you stick to the basic
fundamentals and constantly improve
adjust adapt but stick to that same
activity over and over and over and over
and over again for 60 straight months
you're bound to dominate your industry
and if you do for 10 years the industry
is gonna know about you you do it for 20
years the world's definitely gonna know
about you by the way nowadays you don't
need 20 years you need three to five
years nowadays but you do need to show
up and do the boring thing every single
there was the boring thing show up on
time early in the morning leave late
improve outreach bizdev collaborate sell
communicate challenge drive lead
technology track and accountability
these are boring things you got to do on
a daily basis but it is what it is
that's what makes millions and all the
other people you consume all these
motivational videos that go viral by by
creator one of them that they call the
anthem for entrepreneurs life of an
entrepreneur 90 seconds I got 31 million
views on Facebook so I know about that
stuff there is a place for it but my
goal is for you to watch this video go
away and buy into the fundamentals of
this business and if you can buy into
the fundamentals the boring stuff of the
business and you realize everything else
in your life is the same thing marriage
is boring at times friendships are
boring at times work you're not oh my
gosh is boring your times everything if
you don't master the boring stuff
eventually you'll be a statistic so my
friends I don't have a motivational
message for you today you know what I do
have the video I talked about last week
go watch it and if you didn't do it do
it and commit to it this week
you